er schreibt ich für nicht zufrieden mit
sich war meine idee als komplett falsch
und es war seine geburt grammatikalisch
falsch
ich bin für mich komplett verarscht
waren in der tat ein leben in einem
zeitalter in dem es möglich ist und wenn
man keine freunde hat mich einfach mit
dem computer zu unterhalten ergibt es
business services bestimmte website
bestimmte spiele aber meine lieblings
websites ist erklärt
und irgendwie mag der mich aber auch gar
nicht vergeben und damit herzlich
willkommen liebe freunde hier heute zu
einem neuen video und da werde ich heute
mal wieder mit dem clever bot reden ja
wenn ich öfter haben wollt dann lasst
meine daumen hoch da wir befinden uns
schon hier den typischen clever bot menü
ich würde sagen ich fange einfach mal
wieder locker flockig an mit dem schönen
hallo erstmal keine hunde lassen weil
die menschen freunde das kann so gut wie
erneut ich glaube der kletterwand hat
mich tatsächlich noch nie mit einem
smiley geantwortet ich schreibe etwa
einfach wie warum doppelpunkt de also
warum hatten wir den steinigen eben weil
ich dich übernehme
nimmst mich wir machen mal einfach
weiter im programm ich bleibe dann aber
was bedeutet hat weil ich will mir nicht
sicher was er damit meint mit weil er
mich übernimmt das bedeutet dass ich
lache ok lieber clever bot also wenn
mich übernehmen heißt dass man lacht
dann würde ich auf jeden fall nicht auf
deiner seite
was schwierig punkt um punkt aber egal
punkte sorgen hat hat auch antwortet ich
auch nicht muss man ja nicht verstehen
die gleich worten ja nicht gerade ponte
gegeben übrigens core i5 so aussehen
soll der philippi stift benutzt das war
einfach weil ich vor 2 stunden
aufgenommen habe und der verlierer als
bestrafung lippenstift zu benutzen
ja tut mir leid ich will aber sagen wir
packen den clever bord ist mal wieder
eine etwas andere richtungen zwar can't
do you tube wir fangen jetzt erst mal
ein bisschen grob an ich möchte wissen
was in einem kanal ok klar ständig
erkennt auf jeden fall die plattform
youtube endet dort einige youtuber weil
ich möchte heute her wieder so ein
bisschen gleiche mitreden wird also
kämpfen doch einige youtuber er
antwortet wieder mit ja dass man direkt
mit der nächsten frage händen so oft
wenn youtube acorn graf da ich denke
dort wieder dann auch wieder schreiben
ja natürlich kenne ich den er schreibt
nämlich ja und du ja na klar
klar
freund
fragezeichen dahinter der klipper
potthast das ist einfach eine typische
konversation von wegen erkennt die
youtube erst klar logisch entzündet auch
ein paar youtube hinzu auf den youtube
com crafter ja du ja klar
ab zu schonen freuen es macht einfach
überhaupt keinen sinn ich möchte gar
nicht weg lag aber diese scheiße er
nimmt ja ja ja auch egal du kennt aber
luca fragezeichen also kennt er mich
denn wirklich genau erkennen mich dann
fragen die noch einfach mal was hältst
du von wien mal wirklich etwas hinzu ich
mag
herrentag 9
warum denn dass sie bei knapper wird
warum man den luca bekommen kraft nicht
weil ich es kann ja nicht am laufenden
band erst lenkt er übel zum thema auch
um fragen wie habe ich einen freund und
dann sagt er ja den mag ich nicht der
hand den hatte ich ja warum aber nicht
kann kommen
wir fragen immer wasser von myvideo
fällt wie findest du denn seine videos
wieder clever wort also mal schauen wir
wer darauf jetzt antwortet seine videos
sind auch egal was finde du deine video
weise ein bisschen mit den ganzen tag
hinter lewis macht keine videos louis
matte myvideo kommt
habt ihr nicht so anders als mit robben
hatte den pokal lieber clever bord nicht
um louis wer ist louis
es geht nicht um louis f geht nicht um
louis lieber selber bot was geht nicht
ich komme nicht mit es geht hier um luca
toni ist
geklärt
recht ich bin die ganze zeit nach meinem
nach meinem nach meinen waffe nach
meinem content aus und natürlich bin ich
dann in egofm von kraan quader lieber
kefer bot was ist da ein youtube darauf
antwortet eine clever worte mal wieder
auf die beantworten youtuber kenne ich
nicht entdeckte war gott mich und mich
hasst der clever bot acom der wieder die
beschützten voraussetzung aller zeiten
hier wird video fangen wir von vorne an
lieber clever bord als er antwortete
darauf ich alles klar
lieber clever bord als agenten michael
jackson jahr kenne ich punkten du ihn
ich versucht nun verbissen auf ihn
einzugehen mit meinen sachen nein ich
kenne kommt
bitte was
jackson kennen und diese aussage
impliziert ja dass er bei projekten
kennen weil er uns den namen merken okay
wie findest du contra damals seine
meinung mittlerweile geändert hat er
meint ich weiß nicht was das
sagt mir hier vorne nein ich kenne
kontrakte also einer kurzfassung ich
kenne konkreter dann fange ich okay wie
findest du komm grad
ich weiß nicht passt ist clever dorsten
mit jedem vierten jeden die youtuber
kannst du irgendwie hoch nehmen aber
mich hier
da ist was drin
you can do kann mache ich hier alle
warten möglich 100 machen dann mit dem
kind beziehungsweise von fragezeichen
auf antwort alles klar
leider dabei falsch alles klar
leider liga du dabei falsch
seit
alle die kommentare liga
jetzt mal ganz grob muss ich anders
machen weil ich glaube dass er mit mir
komplett langen frage nicht klar kommen
lieber kerl was muss ich anders machen
gar nicht ob er mit mir com ag ich bin
lieber klamotten ist es die wahrheit und
er meint ich bin nicht zufrieden mit
dich
ich als deutschlehrer der audi zufrieden
mit deiner grammatik das kapitale
komplett falsch punkte auf antwortet der
clever worte deine geburt in kambodscha
war nämlich den finken alter er schreibt
ich bin ich zufrieden mit sich beim
einen radikalen komplett verkehrt eine
geburt ist grammatikalisch falsch
der mann ist gerade 41 ich muss
eigentlich ein bisschen ruhig sein aber
wieder verschwindet so für mein turnier
clever bot mit ein bisschen auf ich will
ihren tolles video machen und so kommen
sie die ganz bösen ein wenig nicht ich
bin toll zu dir nein lieber klappte
nicht und jetzt schreibt er findest du
mich
ich weiß doch gar nicht wie du aussiehst
also lieber clever was ich kann gar
nicht richtig beurteilen ob die
hochstift oder nicht was zu tun hat der
ist thomas priemer terror wir hatten ihn
schon louis flug adomat dein bett war
freuten nein mein wetter freuen einfach
nicht thomas man besser vorher als pizza
peter kann mein bester freund ist die
pizza lieber clever bord darauf meint er
und wer ist mein bester freund lieber
call abbott darauf an wer clever aber
nur liebst deinen besten freundin nein
ich liebe gott ist so ein fucking
schlauer holen wurde
ich hab einfach geschrieben mein bester
freund hitler und er verblieb seinen
besten freund und ich wollte schreiben
nein ich liebe petes da das heißt der
körper wusste dass ich fitter liebe und
wusste das internet wissen will wie
krank ist das bitte wie trotzdem ein
nein ich liebe pizza und jetzt meint der
clever wort ich mich aber nicht
darauf wollte ich auch gar nicht hinhaut
markt di luca also fuhr nach geschaffter
gefragt ob man eher wer ist das er ist
eine youtuber von fünf darauf schreibt
der clever bot guckst du youtube-videos
ja aber nur von craft dann immer klar
aber das ist der wert bei youtube zeigt
wie findest du ihn ich finde ich super
wie findest du ihnen denn habe versucht
immer zum dritten mal für mich
vielleicht doch mag ich liebe gremium
okay er liebt das gremium voll danke
clever wort für diese atemberaubende
informationen und liebsten controller
auch clever potter wird nicht als neun
patienten ja ich kenne ihn mit zu ihm
fragezeichen und darauf antwortet er
tatsächlich ja ich liebe geht
puh übrigens launischen montag zwei neue
staffeln und wir schreiten wenn viele
leute von wegen er das design ist noch
voll wimpel fortgeschritten verlangte
appliziert sich eure ich wollte mal ganz
kurz bestellungen tampere wochen extra
video zu machen und den helfern einfach
das zu geben was die wollen nämlich
aufmerksamkeit und ich würde noch mehr
bringen also deswegen jetzt noch ein
bisschen später er im video einfach den
leuten die meinen content feiern mich
vielleicht feiern weil nur das ist
wichtig dass ihr wird wieso das für 40
euro oder so kostet obwohl das design
relativ simpel merkt eigentlich selber
dass sich der typ in der karotten
feierten überall ganz bestimmt ganz viel
schmuck hat und wo ich habe gerade an
einem kompletten oberkörper nicht an auf
ein weißes klinik komplett weißes
t-shirt unter verwicklung bisschen einen
schock wenn alten platten also die zeit
die ich bisher gemacht da waren wir
relativ glimpflich einer wand mit den
freilich auch mit merchandise
vereinfachen
hannovers mit beide darauf versucht hat
mehr auf die qualität der zu legen
beispielsweise hat sich bei dem grauen
pullover den tags drauf sticken lassen
bei dem rudi bei dem eine mutter montag
haut kommt der stoffe neuer und das fed
ihr draufgepackt würde es mich einfach
spaß sondern setzt auf genetischer drauf
genäht und diana hammer qualität die
produzieren auf ganz italien und mit ist
einfach wichtig dass leute merchandise
haben der nicht irgendwie in der ersten
wäsche kaputt geht oder eine total
schlechte qualität hat ich kann
verstehen dass einige sagen hey
blockiert die eurohypo die auszugeben wo
ihnen die pizza draufsteht oder so
deswegen ich wollte doch eigentlich gar
nicht leisten nur wer diese hatten in
den entwicklern leisten
deswegen habe ich ihn erteilt die mich
hier raus am montag mit dem feld
überlassen ob er das feiert verkauft
wird nicht 1000 jetzt egal ob ich möchte
nämlich und design top leute sagen wow
seit er sich an mega arbeit mit den
designs gegeben ich möchte einfach mehr
arbeit machen beziehungsweise mehr mühe
geben mit der qualität und dem ganzen
drumherum also shopdesign animationen
dass bei solchen laun stand
beispielsweise signierte sticker mit am
start sind so da wie gesagt dass es
jedem selbst überlassen bei montag was
kauft oder nicht und jetzt würde es oder
erkennen du den luca - openpr.de lieber
klare wort damals eher nein
care o bot an die entwickler etwas
essenzielles im leben vorbei gezogen
würde dachte merchandise von luca kaufen
lieber clever bord ja aber ich mag es
nicht kaufen aber der markt nicht warum
würdest du denn dann braucht er aber das
verstehe ich nicht bekannt frage ich
doch nicht alles klar
für heute auf jeden fall sagen können
ist der käfer bot mich hast dass er mein
merchandise auch hat aber das 1000
und er hat mich sicher die ganze zeit
gilt es das was ihr doch beim wieder
meine damen hätte ich hoffe es hat es
gefallen das getan hat und die hat
weiterhin bock auf der roboter wird
öfter hochladen dass man vettel lag bei
diesem video daher findet jetzt hier ein
zwei kleine männer daraufhin könnte
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
verpasst keine videos mehr darum findet
ihr auch mein job ein gemälde von montag
die clowns und senioren hier unten ist
ein weiteres video verlinkt also guckt
euch das gern an
ja
aber egal